[Applaudissements]
ap
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
là ce lecteur dvd
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
échec et mat
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
fini de leur sang
c'est la fin des temps des mecs se
tromper c'est un vrai plus
game over haut mais vous fait quoi là on
est le nouveau vilain coup de main vous
est pris pour qu'y penser qu'on a besoin
de vous les mecs quand même un peu non
de classe 1 ne s'est pas super efficace
quoi ok venu chercher la merde en fait
c'est ça non mais c'est juste que ça
fait mille ans que vous couriez après un
gars donc au bout d'un moment on savait
ni ridicule tu as dis quoi là on va te
montrer qu'il est ridicule
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je prends les attend
jean paul adam nos jours bien
possible
regard
[Musique]
bonjour moi je veux rien avoir de
dongguan et de l'eau bagages de la
police enfin je souhait de courir du
brésil mais je suis là juste pour dire
que vous abonner à tous les jeunes de
mon titre in la police zougoise et un
sourire à tout autour de toulouse n'a ni
eau
selon police du japon tous les maux
stein d'ailleurs je crois qu'il a dit
sur mes épaules et ça les polices
peuvent sortir de cette pièce ok nous
allons partir nous la police